hello grammarians today we're going to
talk about two of my well i don't know
if i'd call them favorite but two of my
most frequently confused words i make
this mistake all the time
you know and i think it's important to
keep it straight so affect
and effect
are two very different words what is the
difference you might ask well that's why
i'm here so
to sum it up let's just put the tldr
right at the top
affect is a verb just think of that as a
verb an effect think of that as a noun
it's more complicated than that
obviously but most of the time when
you're looking at these two words and
you're trying to decide ah which one do
i use um affect is a verb effect is a
noun that's that's the too long didn't
read of this video and who reads a video
but this is this is your key takeaway
let me let me give you some examples so
okay so let's take this sentence the
drought had a nasty blank on angela's
crops
now
both of these words
mean
something happened
right they both
they both mean that there was a change
but effect with an e is the result of
that change and affect with an a or
effect uh is
the changing
is the change agent if that makes sense
so
we're looking at this sentence the
drought had a nasty blank on angela's
crops we know we need to use one of
those well we're signaling here by using
the article a and you know this
adjective nasty that we're looking for a
noun so we'd want to say the drought had
a nasty effect
another way to say to think of this is
effect with an e is the same way as
saying
result
similarly if we wanted to write this
sentence again
but with affect with a verb we'd say
the drought affected angela's crops
so affect we're using it as a verb
effect we're using it as a noun and i'm
i'm exaggerating the pronunciation of
those just to give you
to give you the distinction
now of course there are always obnoxious
uh exceptions let's cover them briefly
but just bear in mind that these are
pretty rare
okay so number one
the word effect with an e as verb
when you see this as a verb um it
usually means to create so the way the
way i usually see this uh is in the
phrase effect change
which really means to to bring about
change effect here means to create
so kimiko hoped that the new mayor would
effect change in her town what we're
saying here is really make change when
we say effect as a verb that's that's
really just means to make
and the other
obnoxious exception
is affect
as a noun
which is a like a psychology term it
really means like someone's personality
so for example percy had a smug affect
and that just means that
his personality is smug
now i i want to hit again that these are
these are exceptions and they're pretty
rare and i would
caution
avoiding them most of the time
i think your big takeaway is that affect
is a verb and effect is a noun and yes
these exceptions exist
but i think in the interest of clarity
you need to be very certain when you're
using them because affect here as a noun
is professional jargon frankly this is
this is psychologist talk
and that means it's a very particular
kind of english it's to be used in a
specific context likewise effect has a
verb frankly
i don't know what you get out of this i
would just say make
frankly like i'm not sure it's worth the
confusion but that's just a style tip
obviously it's still grammatical to use
it that way uh you just have to be
careful of confusion so what's the
takeaway
affect is a verb effect is a noun but
there are exceptions
you can learn anything dave it out